bonjour à tous et merci d'être avec nous
c'est l'heure de parlement hebdo nous
sommes ensemble pour 45ème minute pour
revoir les temps forts de la semaine
politique bonjour michaëlle jean catelas
l'actualité parlementaire c'est
l'adoption d'une proposition de loi pour
lutter contre la prostitution vote sans
surprise le texte prévoit notamment de
sanctionner le client d'une
contravention de 1500 euros
le sujet sensible continue de diviser au
delà des clivages
l'ump cherche l'unité alain juppé
françois fillon fait meeting commun
bordeaux un premier pas en attendant le
rassemblement pour les municipales une
initiative sur fond de sondages pour
et puis le plus de l'hebdo vous parle
d'avenir rendez vous dans un peu plus de
10 ans en 2025 peut être l'année d'une
nouvelle exposition universelle après
celle de 1940 la france souhaite
l'accueillir le projet est mené
notamment par deux parlementaires ou va
en parler tout à l'heure avec notre
invité
justement j'ai intestins probante à
vaujours bonjour et député vous siégez
au groupe
udi maire de neuilly sur seine depuis
2008 vous êtes le président de
l'association expo france 2025 on en
parlera bien évidemment un petit peu
plus tard dans cette émission mais je
vous propose d'écouter avant de parler
de toute l'actualité d'écouter deux
collègues vous parlementaire il parle un
petit peu de vous et puis vous vous
réagirez juste après un député présent
assidus et
c'est quelqu'un qui intervient toujours
avec des arguments de fond quand il
prend la parole il est écouté parce que
ce sont des arguments qui sont qui sont
pensés ciselés avec une position qui est
toujours une position raisonnable là et
je me retrouve très souvent dans les
propos qu'il peut tenir ici dans
l'hémicycle ou en réunions commission il
avait une mission qui avait été confiée
par jean louis borloo sur l'élaboration
du projet du diy les choses n'ont pas
prospéré aujourd'hui est comment dire
c'est un électron libre qui vit sa
propre vie en toute indépendance et qui
n'a aucun rôle dans le collectif
je respecte ses positions et je pense
qu'il serait bien qu'il respecte aussi
les positions des autres quand elles ne
sont pas conformes aux siennes
ouais bon ce qui fâche on va parler des
choses mieux mais d'abord ce qui fâche
yves jégo qui vous dit que vous êtes un
électron libre difficile à gérer
vous aviez participé à l'élaboration du
projet eut dit vous avez mis un petit
peu de côté pourquoi vous ne croyez pas
à ce grand centre qui est en train de
créer mais il ya peu à peu près un peu
plus d'un an
si vous voulez je crois que un projet
politique doit se bâtir sur un socle et
qui est le socle d'un projet politique
c'est pas tant des éléments de programme
des idées nouvelles ou des slogans dans
certains cas c'est un socle de valeurs
c'est un socle de valeurs fortes qui
peuvent être différentes d'ailleurs mais
il faut qu'à un moment un mouvement
politique et le courage de débattre sur
les valeurs et de l'est et de les mettre
de les construire comme élément
fondamental 5 avril à l'éthique et je
crois qu'elle udi et on n'a pas réussi à
avoir ce débat on a donc j'ai travaillé
sur le projet pendant plusieurs mois et
quand j'ai vu que finalement sur les
fondamentaux n'ont pas les éléments de
programme encore une fois mais les
éléments fondamentaux
il y avait des écarts j'ai demandé à ce
qu'on ait un débat sur les valeurs
ce débat n'intéresse pas beaucoup en fin
de compte et je crois que c'est vrai
pour ludivine c'est vrai pour beaucoup
de partis on est emporté dans les landes
en l'homme risque clientéliste le risque
du court terme le risque dû à la réponse
aux éléments de l'actualité des
conjectures des lobbys et c est que
voilà la france est un projet politique
a besoin qu'on le construit sur vue sur
un socle pour d'autres
votre positionnement yves jégo parle
d'électron libre est ce que vous vous
reconnaissez dans ce dans ce
qualificatif comment vous définiriez
quel est exactement votre position
aujourd'hui leurs électrons livia libre
électron médias libres mais un électron
ne peut se mettre dans une dynamique où
il ya beaucoup d'électrons qui se met
dans une dynamique c'est comme ça qu'on
fait l'énergie mais libre ça veut dire
ne pas être inféodé ne pas être
discipliné oui je crois que lui a cette
force c'est de ne pas se construire
comme la partie verticale il ya le mot
indépendant alors si eu d y accepte le
moulin hideux indépendant il faut
accepter et yves jégo comme les autres
doit accepter cette indépendance
cette indépendance c'est à gages de
créativité c'est un gage de débat
interne c'est pas facile c'est beaucoup
plus dur et on le voit au travers
d'aidés des deux des deux remarques
c'est beaucoup plus dur de construire un
projet politique avec des gens
indépendants donc qu'ils sont libres et
qu'ils sont forts sur leurs convictions
fort sur leur projet fort aussi leur
ancrage territoriaux que de caporaliser
je veux voir qu'une seule tête et c'est
pas ça lui dit c'est pas ça mon projet
politique je vous allez nous le dira
évidemment un mot quand même sur les
élections municipales à venir
vous êtes toujours candidat à neuilly
sur seine il paraît qu'il ya beaucoup de
monde en ce moment qui serait possible
candidat à neuilly sur seine
tout d'abord jean sarkozy fils de
nicolas sarkozy qui voulait deuxième sur
votre liste finalement non non pourquoi
mais pour toujours pour la même chose
vous voyez être libre c'est faire
d'abord ses propos de pouvoir proposer
aux gens un projet pas une alliance de
système pas tiens je vais prendre lui
parce qu'il représente tel parti lui
parce qu'ils représentent telle personne
lui c'est pas comme ça qu'on monte une
organisation qui marche on monte une
organisation qui marchent en disant
voilà j'ai un projet pour ma ville je
fais une analyse j'ai un projet pour ma
ville et j'ai le devoir vis-à-vis de mes
électeurs de bâle regio mettant vous
avez eu des pressions pajer-u oui j'ai
pas mal de pression mais j'en avais eu
les très fortes en 2008 j'avais tenu le
cap je tiens toujours le cas voudront
tout est un nouveau coup de trafalgar de
l'ump si je puis dire au dernier moment
avec un quotidien trop flatteur plus que
lui dit dans le reportage que vous avez
montré non je crois que oui je je je je
prends des risques je l'assument
mais voyez je préfère rester libre et
prendre des risques que mettre les pieds
sous la table maffeo d'epernay liberté
alors jean christophe fromantin on va
parler lundi du dimanche avec une
nouvelle loi peut-être sur le travail
dominical c'est en tout cas le souhait
de jean marc ayrault sur le fondement du
rapport que lui a remis
jean paul bailly chargée du dossier
conclusion pas de régime dérogatoire
pour les anciennes de bricolage et la
possibilité pour les commerces d'ouvrir
jusqu'à douze dimanches par an nhs sous
certaines conditions ravi car après un
mois de travail
jean paul bailly tient entre ses mains
les cent pages d'un rapport censé
clarifier la réglementation complexe qui
régit le travail du dimanche
la question n'est donc pas des tendres
plus ou moins la possibilité du travail
le dimanche
elle existe déjà dans certains cas mais
de le faire dans de meilleures
conditions aujourd'hui c'est à dire des
conditions plus clair plus simple
comprise par tous le rapport refuse de
créer de nouvelles dérogations dont
bénéficient déjà les magasins
d'ameublement et les jardineries
mais il recommande de passer de cinq à
douze le nombre d'ouvertures autorisé le
dimanche il envisage aussi de remettre à
plat la carte des zones autorisées à
ouvrir et rend obligatoire le régime
social de compensation et concernant
l'ouverture des magasins de bricolage le
dimanche
jean paul bailly propose une solution
spécifique dans ce secteur-là
les commerces qui auront
mis en oeuvre ou atteints soit un accord
soit une mise en oeuvre approuvée par
référendum pourront effectivement ouvrir
le dimanche
des concertations avec le gouvernement
les parlementaires et les syndicats sont
prévues prochainement pour élaborer une
nouvelle loi sur le travail du dimanche
qui entrerait en vigueur dès 2014 alors
faut-il ou non une nouvelle loi pour
essayer de mieux régir le travail le
dimanche est dans votre commune
neuilly-sur-seine que feriez vous je
pense qu'on a besoin d'une loi pour
réguler et organiser un peu les choses
parce qu'il ya des incohérences il ya
des dysfonctionnements il ya des choses
qui sont pas claires donc on a besoin
d'une d'une loi moi je pense que il ya
deux pistes raisonnable il ya certains
secteurs d'activité sur lequel ça peut
avoir du sens le bricolage peut peut en
être un il ya les zones touristiques a
précisé de la crétinisation des zones
touristiques ensuite fondamentalement
moi je suis pas pour le travail le
dimanche
ouvert à tout le monde tout le temps
faim préserver de sacro-saintes dimanche
à moi je la sais partie nos briques il
le dit vous aussi je voulais moi je suis
très très préoccupé par cette idée de
2,2 m
de construire une semaine qui est à
différencier une semaine où le dimanche
est traité comme le lundi où comme le
mardi je pense qu a besoin de
respiration c'est exigeant parce que la
tentation fonctionnaliste consumériste
est très forte mais et puisqu'on
consomme le dimanche on consomme pas le
reste de la semaine donc l'argument sur
l'emploi et quand même pas évident à
traiter donc moi je suis extrêmement
réservé sur le travail le dimanche pour
tout le monde tout le temps partout
parce que je crois qu'on détruit de la
valeur sociale fondamentale dans notre
pays passer à un autre sujet sur la
fiscalité des consultations se
poursuivent à matignon jean marc ayrault
a reçu les présidents de groupe ump à
l'assemblée et au sénat jérôme ravier
ils ont voté contre le projet de loi de
finances 2014 au sénat la semaine
dernière ce matin c'est la réforme
fiscale de jean marc ayrault qu'ils sont
venus défier l'ump ouvre le bal et
dénonce un flou total
pas de calendrier pas de méthode pas de
cap
on embrasse large on évoque tous les
sujets
mon premier ministre nous dit qu'il va
concertée qu'il évoquera la méthode plus
tard la calendrier plus tard oc et le
cap
je ne sais pas s'il sera évoqué un jour
le sénateur jean claude gaudin lui
ironise sur la communication du premier
ministre qui avait d'abord annoncé son
projet à la presse et goûter pour
l'instant nous sommes les informer
c'est déjà pas mal puisque le parlement
n'avait pas été en premier alors que ces
usages normalement merci au final
l'opposition de droite rejette surtout
l'absence de baisses d'impôts dans cette
réforme
du côté du front de gauche on soutient
une grande réforme fiscale mais avec des
demandes bien précises particulièrement
lamination delà de l'augmentation de la
tva a au 1er janvier 2014 et yann
certain nombre de mesures qui seraient
intéressants à prendre du côté du grand
des grandes entreprises est en résumé de
s'attaquer enfin aux coûts du capital et
non pas au coût du travail
les parlementaires communistes veulent
désormais présenter un contre projet des
états généraux vont être lancées pour
aboutir rapidement à une proposition de
loi à les élus locaux ont été reçus
également en milieu de semaine est-ce
qu'il faut une fiscalité pour les élues
locales pour les communes très précises
par exemple est ce qu'il faut comme le
précise certains utilisaient à cg pour
financer les communes c'est je crois que
c'est ce qui pour moi est complètement
absurde dans ce qui est cette séquence
fiscal de consultation c'est que la
fiscalité n'est qu'un outil au service
d'un projet de société ou d'un projet
politique
la fiscalité aides et demande d'abord à
ce qu'on rebaptise à une structuration
des compétences en france
quelles compétences pour l'état quelles
compétences pour des régions pour moi je
plaide pour des grandes régions
quelles compétences par rapport à une
simplification du millefeuille
territorial et quelle doctrine fiscale
il ya deux doctrines fiscales qui sont
possibles où on a juste le budget chaque
année avec la dépense publique où on a
juste le budget de chaque année avec la
fiscalité les socialistes a juste
j'ai chaque année avec la fiscalité est
malheureusement la droite pendant
longtemps ajusté aussi avec la fiscalité
et je crois que si on n'a pas ce débat
n'a aucun sens si on n'a pas avant des
grandes assises oui où je peux je des
grands grenelle je sais pas quoi puisque
l objet de la france pour moi on met
vraiment les choses il est complètement
à l'envers avec ce projet s'est assise
en même temps c'est un peu les douze
travaux d'hercule si vous vous étiez à
la tête de ce chantier gigantesque vous
commenceriez par quoi quel serait votre
priorité
la réforme du modèle pour moi on a un
modèle d'organisation territoriale
hérité de la fin du xviiie siècle qui
avait sont intéressés sa justification à
ce moment là qui n'a plus aujourd'hui
une réforme de l'état a finalement c'est
une réforme de l'état et je préfère dire
une réforme des territoires parce que le
politique il est la forme gérer des
territoires il est là pour s'occuper de
tous ceux qui vivent dans nos
territoires locaux évidemment des
communes et du coup effectivement où il
faut repartir du bas des territoires du
principe de subsidiarité et à l'aune
d'un projet de territoire de gouvernance
qui monte jusqu'à l'état et jusqu'à
l'europe redistribuer la fiscalité en
fonction d'une redistribution des
compétences et là on fait les choses
complètement à l'envers
alors on va passer au mardi avec une
mauvaise nouvelle pour la france la
france perd du terrain dans le domaine
de la réussite scolaire elle se classe
au 25e rang des pays de l'osce et des
oeufs c'est le résultat de l'étude
internationale pisa en notre code un
programme international qui évalue le
niveau scolaire dans le monde entier
le sujet a évidemment fait réagir dans
l'hémicycle l amont d'un gaza après la
mauvaise note française au classement
pisa le président de l'udps et y appelle
les députés à se rassembler autour de
l'école
nous souhaitons que le rapport pisa ne
soit pas l'enjeu de polémiques inutiles
ou stériles mais l'objet d'un sursaut
républicain
nous sommes prêts nous à une union
nationale autour de l'école de la
république
une initiative saluée par le ministre de
l'éducation
je vous remercie du ton que vous avez
adopté
et de l'appel que vous lancez je
considère en effet et c'est bien la
priorité du président de la république
que nous devons mener en chambre toute
la nation
la refondation républicaine de l'école
pourtant tout l'après-midi majorité
opposition n'ont cessé de se rejeter la
faute
l'enquêté pisa n'a été fait entre 2003
et mai 2012 et donc c'est un constat
implacable de ce que chacun pouvait voir
la façon et été laissé à l'abandon
notre système d'éducation public les
baisses d'effectifs professeur les
baisses d'enseignants et autres à nous
dire que ce sont les décisions prises en
2008 en 2009 qui pose des problèmes pour
les gamins qui sont rentrés à l'école
primaire en 2002 et s'ils ont juste
d'avoir un minimum d'honnêteté
intellectuelle
ça ferait du bien aux débats éducatifs
un appel à l'unité finalement bien peu
relayée aucun parti politique ne veut se
voir attribuer le bonnet d'âne alors
quand jean louis borloo patron de l'udps
et il lance un appel à l'unité nationale
autour de l'école de la république
vous soutenez à 100% oui bien entendu je
crois que il faut il faut sur des sujets
comme ça essayer de trouver un des
grandes lignes directrices mais mais en
même temps on voit bien qu'un sujet
comme ça nécessite des grandes réformes
des grandes réformes de structure et que
ces réformes sont extrêmement difficiles
à assumer par les partis politiques
parce qu'elles sont inconfortables en
terme de messages et en termes de
projets donc le le sujet pisa et le
sujet sur l'éducation et mais il rejoint
il rejoint notre notre question
précédente un cd regarder les allemands
en 2001 quand ils ont sept cette alerte
rouge avec le relais avec la même
enquête
ils ont tout remis à plat et l'ont remis
en repartant des territoires il ne sait
pas faire ça territorialisée une partie
d'éducation pour faire justement des
bons ajustements
ce qui manque aujourd'hui c'est une
adaptation une réadaptation de
l'éducation de la formation à des
réalités issus de la mondialisation des
problèmes de compétitivité et
d'adaptation d'une éducation d'une
formation à des réalités économiques
nouvelles
ce résultat fait il partie d'une forme
de déclinisme de la france un sondage
paru cette semaine son âge c'est ça qui
dit que trois quarts des français
estiment que la france est en déclin
ils ont pas tout à fait tort
la france ne veut pas voir un monde qui
a changé la france reste sur sa matrice
sur sa structure qu'est celle qu'on a
hérité du début du 20e siècle et essaye
de faire dans cette matrice dans cette
structure les ajustements pour s'adapter
mais il ya un moment ce comme des gens
dans une entreprise quand le modèle nos
pères pucon la concurrence a changé il
faut changer de modèle et changer de
modèle pour un projet politique c'est
faire des réformes de structure et les
faire de manière cohérente
on ne peut pas isoler le sujet de la
compétitivité le sujet économique du
sujet social du sujet de l'éducation est
donc là encore des assises de la
fiscalité où on ouvre un chantier
indépendamment de sujet de l'éducation
ont fait des réformes territoriales qui
ne sont pas qu'ils ne rencontrent pas
ces grands sujets là il est temps
d'avoir une approche globale logique
cohérente convergentes aussi de la
parole politique 75% du même sondage
estiment que l'image de politique est
négative
ça doit vous aussi vous interpeller mais
oui parce que le l'opinion nous dit vous
n'êtes pas capable d'avoir une approche
pour la france c'est d'ailleurs on le
voit dans les sondages conduits aux gens
ce que vous êtes heureux ils disent
plutôt oui majoritairement quand on dit
est ce que vous croyez à votre pays ils
disent non et il ya ce paradoxe et en
disant en fin de compte voilà j'ai les
moyens d'être heureux mais il n'y a pas
on entraîne pas on m'emmène pas sur un
chemin collectif de renouveau
d'espérance d'avenir comment vous faites
vous jean christophe fromantin pour
ramener les citoyens sur ce chemin
d'espérance de confiance d'avenir va les
faire participer à un projet avec leur
liberté bel avantage de quelqu'un qui
n'est pas dans le champ politique c'est
qu'il aura la liberté de d'amener dans
l'analyse des regards nouveaux d'amener
dans l'analyse des compétences nouvelles
d'amener dans l'analyse des solutions
nouvelles à prendre alors que l'homme
politique qui dit vous là attention là
je vais être impopulaire je touche pas
là on va me et il est embarqué voyez
quand
le lui dis ou son porte parole dit il
joue pas collectif c'est simplement il
se met pas dans la kz2 ce qui évite les
dégâts collatéraux des décisions qu'on
peut prendre pour les allées au sujet
mercredi l'assemblée vote à une
proposition de loi sur la prostitution
les clients des prostituées seront
bientôt pénalisé c'est l'une des mesures
phares du vote qui a eu lieu cette
semaine à l'assemblée nationale d'une
proposition loi de faire l'unanimité
mario lefebvre pour 268 contre 138
l'assemblée nationale a adopté la
proposition de loi sur la prostitution
est votée elle a suscité les débats
la polémique voir le malaise pendant les
discussions mais elle a obtenu une
majorité dans l'hémicycle un vote saluée
par la ministre
c'est une étape importante aujourd'hui
parce que vous voyez bien la teneur des
débats qui ont eu lieu
c'est compliqué la lutte contre la
prostitution à quelques exceptions elle
les socialistes ont voté le texte
parfois sans conviction moi j'ai voté
pour mais sans angélisme et sans un
enthousiasme débordant en considérant
que c'est une avancée qu'il fallait
saluer le travail important qui avait
été fait mais que de toute façon on aura
ajuster le tir au fur et à mesure de la
mise en oeuvre de cette loi à droite et
chez les verts certains députés étaient
favorables à la loi mais la majorité s'y
est opposée on va pénaliser
les clients aux terres en pensant que ça
va arrêter la prostitution de qu'est ce
qu'il est ce que fait la prostitution
elle va se déplacer va se faire dans des
lieux beaucoup plus insalubres en fait
brand empire la condition de ces pauvres
filles nous considérons que c'est la
clandestinité qui nourrit ses réseaux
criminels mafieux de traite des êtres
humains
malheureusement cette loi avec la
pénalisation du client va plutôt en
rajouter un peu dans la clandestinité
quand d'enlever voilà pourquoi nous
votons majoritairement contre désormais
ce sont les clients qui seront punis
1500 euros damende le double en cas de
récidive
le délit de racolage passif est abrogé
la loi entend responsabiliser les
clients et renforcer la protection des
victimes de proxénétisme
ainsi les prostituées qui veulent
quitter la profession seront accompagnés
dans leur parcours les étrangères
pouvons obtenir un titre de séjour de
six mois si elle s'engage à quitter la
prostitution
qu'est-ce que vous avez voté jean
christophe fromantin j'ai voté pour
pourquoi parce qu'un accord n'est pas
une marchandise oui et je crois que même
si la loi et je rejoins ce que certains
ont dit et est imparfaite est incomplète
et ne résoudra pas le problème
envoyer un signal fort sur la demande
est fondamentale
comprenez un petit peu le malaise qui
règne à droite et à gauche sur ce texte
c'est un sujet compliqué et c'est un
texte compliqué et on sait bien que la
solution aller voir personne n'a la
science infuse sur un sujet comme ça
personne là mais en même temps voilà il
faut quand même envoyé des signaux
responsabiliser ceux qui sont quand même
à l'origine de la prostitution c'est le
consommateur qui fait la prostitution
c'est la demande qui se développent et
donc je le signale était nécessaire bon
mois voilà moi j'ai voté pour cent et
atteint derrière quand même des réseaux
vous dit que vous ne pensez pas tout de
même que ce projet de loi va renforcer
la clandestinité la précarité l
influence de ces réseaux non parce que
je pense que malheureusement ce projet
doit elle n'aura que des effets assez
marginaux sur le problème de la
prostitution qui dépasse bien bien
entendu ce projet de loi mais comme le
problème problème des réseaux le
problème de l' esclavage mode
un convoi dans toute une série de
d'expression aujourd'hui c'est un
problème politique internationale dont
il faut saisir là aussi de manière à la
source
je pense pas que c'est une loi sur la
prostitution qui va qui va résoudre le
problème qui se déplacera
géographiquement dans d'autres pays
changer la ville n'était du monde donc
responsabilisons les clients et je pense
que là il ya un bon signal on parle
d'une information maintenant qui a
suscité beaucoup de ramdam sur les
réseaux sociaux en février 2011 françois
hollande a été hospitalisé pour une
hypertrophie bénigne de la prostate
c'était avant la primaire socialiste un
communiqué de l'elysée a confirmé cette
information avait par france info
écoutez ces quelques réactions je crois
qu'une fois qu'on devient président de
la république en effet on a une
obligation de transparence
il s'agit de tenir informer les français
sur la capacité qu'on a exercé les
responsabilités qui nous ont été confiés
en tout cas dans le cas du président de
la république mais en l'occurrence sur
le cas de françois hollande
il n'était qu'un candidat en campagne il
ne s'agit pas d'une responsabilité
présidentielle qui doit lui être opposé
je crois que le président candidat en
tout cas aurait gagné à jouer à jouer la
transparence en expliquant qu'il avait
pu avoir un problème de santé
on est toujours rattrapé par ce genre de
choses d'une façon ou d'une autre on l'a
vu avec mitterrand ça a duré pendant des
années c'est un peu empoisonné les
relations avec les uns et des autres je
crois qu'il faut être
il faut être prudent mais je vais
demander un droit au respect de la vie
privée ça me semble essentiel on est à
une époque où en compte sont la
transparence et le voyeurisme et à force
pour certains de s'étaler sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ne savent plus faire
la différence
informations d'intérêt public ou
strictement d'ordre privé est sans
importance pour vous chanter
l'information mais intéressante que si
elle a un impact sur la vie politique ou
sur le quinquennat
aucun la transparence est nécessaire que
si elle est de nature à avoir un impact
ou des conséquences sur la manière de
gérer le pays en l'occurrence ou bruit
pour un projet pour cette annonce
j'ai tout simplement un non sujet non
sujet mais juste une dernière précision
est ce que la france n'est pas un petit
peu malade de tant de secrets d'état
autour de la santé des présidents depuis
de nombreuses années circus il si on ne
dit pas un moment aux français à quoi
sert la transparence la transparence est
nécessaire mais si elle a un sens être
transparents près de transparence c'est
du voyeurisme comme le dit un député est
transparent parce que avoir les manettes
de l'état le bouton de l'armé nucléaire
ah et bien entendu est corrélée à la
santé physique mentale et c'est un sens
donc remettons les choses dans l'ordre
la transparence pur et dur pour la
transparence n'a aucun sens la
transparence quand elle interagit avec
les conséquences que peut avoir un geste
du chef de l'état un sens c'était pas le
cas dans cette dans cette information
propose de passer notre sujet sujet de
l'ump qui jeudi
jouer l'image d'unité françois fillon
alain juppé sur la même estrade pour un
meeting commun près de bordeaux c'est
l'image d'unité que voulait jouer
françois fillon il voulait une image de
photos de famille qui réunissait jusqu'à
jean françois copé qui lui a décliné
reportage chantage armored rio
officiellement c'est une simple réunion
publique pour les municipales la photo
est plutôt inédite françois fillon et
alain juppé côte à côte
tous les deux veulent afficher ce soir
l'image de l'unité
plus qu'une image un symbole un an
presque jour pour jour après la crise
interne pour la présidence de l'ump
à la tribune pas un mot sodomie 17 mai
un appel au rassemblement lancé un appel
à françois jean françois jean pierre
avec maranatha virale et riz à xavier à
laurent à benoît à christian à tous les
autres c'est plutôt que de développer
chacun des stratégies individuelles
eh bien on se mettait ensemble pour
présenter un projet pour la france
est-ce que ça va n'augmenterons pas nos
chances de gagner
nous sommes aujourd'hui coude à coude et
c'est pas seulement un geste d'unité
c'est pas seulement un geste de
confiance mutuelle c'est aussi un
message que nous voulons adresser à tous
ceux qui pensent que l'ump est en mal de
crédibilité si françois fillon est déjà
candidat aux primaires en 2016 pour 2017
alain juppé personnalité politique
préférée des français y réfléchisse
sérieusement mais pour les militants
une seule priorité 2014 et surtout pas
question de revivre une nouvelle guerre
des chefs permettent de faire chacun
dans son coin je crois qu'aujourd'hui le
rassemblement est indispensable
toute la droite se réunit actuellement
parce qu'elle sent que l'heure est grave
par rapport au gouvernement que nous
avons en place qui détruit des emplois
monumentaux et surtout l'économie
c'est un symbole très fort qu'il faut
retenir et porter je pense l'union en
attendant la compétition et les deux
anciens premiers ministres espèrent une
photo de famille élargie l'opposition le
principe est validé par tous mais elle
ne devrait pas avoir lieu avant mi
janvier
alors réconciliation ou simple affichage
on en parle tout de suite c'est le zoom
de parlement hebdo et denis jeambar est
avec nous bonjour bonjour vous êtes
journaliste éditorialiste pour les
chaînes parlementaires
une question à qui profite le plus elle
cette opération réconciliation à
françois fillon ou alain juppé
je crois que ça profite surtout à l'ump
qui en a bien besoin après des mois de
turbulences et qui a peut-être enfin
compris que si elles ne se ressemblent
pas et s'ils ne se divise pas déjà sur
le candidat à la présidentielle eh bien
elle va perdre du terrain compte tenu du
fait d'ailleurs qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui s'organise autour notamment
lui d y ait un centre droit nouveau donc
je crois que c'est un acte
d'intelligence
et par ailleurs je pense que françois
fillon a changé complètement de
stratégie après une stratégie de rupture
il a vu les conséquences de sa douleur
il se pose en rassembleur et ils
essaient maintenant de d'oublier les
propos définitifs sur le front national
est et sur nicolas sarkozy
changement total de stratégie comment
vous voyez-vous l'avenir autres à la gpe
françois fillon c'est que peut-être de
l'udf à l'ump mais sûrement avoir un
oeil averti
je crois dans tous les partis est temps
que les gens percevront dans toutes ses
dents tous ces actualités des stratégies
de personnes et non pas des stratégies
de rassemblement autour d'un projet et
de réformes et deux aux réformes de
structure pour la france finalement ça
fera gagner à court terme peut-être
quelques points et ça fera bouger les
lignes de manière extrêmement ponctuels
et éphémère mais ça n'aura aucune
incidence sur le chiffre que vous
donniez tout à l'heure sur la défiance
des français vis à vis des politiques
ce n'est sûrement pas une question à la
jupe et dit tout autre cas par un tweet
je le cite qu'on lui foute la paix avec
vous pensez vraiment quand il a envie
qu'on lui foute la paix 2010 est dans le
jeu oui sans doute mais je pense qu'ils
y pensent et heureusement moi j'ai une
petite nuance par rapport à ce que vous
dites je crois que la vie politique ce
sont des zones ce sont des hommes qui
incarnent un projet mais il faut arrêter
de nous dire que bah c'est d'abord les
idées et puis les hommes ça vient après
non c'est un homme qui défend des idées
et d'ailleurs on vient de le voir au
fond avec la disparation de demander là
c'était un homme qui portait une grande
idée donc et je trouve que cette
disparition nous le montre la politique
c'est des hommes
et cessons de dire que ce ne sont pas
des hommes se sont que les ide non c'est
les hommes qui portent des idées vous
mais moi je fais un constat je veux bien
toutes les approches mais je fais un
constat un taux de défiance
incroyable comme peu pays on connaît ce
fils et hommes politiques
une situation catastrophique et d'ail et
l'accumulation de non choix des valeurs
qui finalement sont ne sont plus assumer
ne sont plus défendus et pousse les
extrêmes sous les face à ce qu'on a ce
triple constat un constat sur les
convictions un constat sur les projets
un constat sur la confiance
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui dire tout va
bien et là
déjà chien avec machin va changer la
donne on ne fera pas du neuf avec du
vieux
aujourd'hui excusez moi mais on est
toujours avoir les mêmes visages où on
voit les mêmes idées et on pense que
parce que ils vont se réconcilier
on va avoir maintenant des projets pour
ce n'est pas ce que nous ne soyons pas
naïfs la france est dans un état elle
est encalminée mais comme un navire qui
est enfoncé dans la vase
je fais plus aucune raison de le faire
moi j'ai fait ce constat en 2007
oui en dix ans le député qu'on propose
dans ma circonscription est-ce qu'il a
bien compris les enjeux qui y vont j'ai
dit j'y vais pour pousser un coup de
gueule ses trois semaines de campagne
je suis j'ai joué un clip mais je me
suis après pour des circonstances
présentées dans une élection municipale
on m'a dit tu es aucune chance ces
tenues par les partis politiques
bon mais j'ai fait aucune concession en
étant investis par aucun parti et j'ai
été élu et je me suis dit j'ai continué
et je me suis dit j'irai aux
législatives pour porter des idées de
renouveau et je refuserais les
investitures j'ai été élu député sans
rien devoir à personne c'est sa liberté
non mais sous les 7 intègre des
politiques mal aux changements ici tout
le monde
mais le sujet n'est pas moi oui et je
crois qu'il ya des séquences où le sujet
c'est le fond c'est le projet peut-être
après on reviendra des séquences où
c'est les hommes qui incarnent mai et à
un moment oui un moment il faut regarder
la france
il faut regarder les réformes
structurelles on les connaît mais on a
peur de les faire on a peur de toutes
les résistances pourquoi on fait pas de
réforme de l'éducation nationale parce
qu'on a peur des syndicats pourquoi on
fait pas une réforme territoriale parce
qu'on a peur de la réaction des
présidents de conseils généraux
pourquoi on fait pas une réforme
économique parce qu'on la peur d'avoir
du monde dans la rue pourquoi on va pas
au bout de la réforme des retraites
parce qu'on la peur des manifestations
et donc c'est pas des hommes qui font de
la vie politique leur métier qu'ils
pourront attaquer ces réformes il faut
du moins sa vie politique c'est une
mission mais néanmoins cette mission
elle doit être portée par un homme est
la démonstration que vous faites
concernant vous même et la démonstration
que c'est parce qu'un homme d'abord le
doit incarner approcher ses songes
exactement dit s'inspirer exactement toa
système pour mais pourquoi j'ai condamné
l'alliance borloo bayrou c'est que ces
deux systèmes de partie c'est pas de
projet c'est pas une vision de la france
alors on a vite fait un petit écriture
commune pour lui donner un peu de
consistance
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière
honnêtement et
pareil pour ce reportage convient de
voir donc et ça je crois que les
français ils n'en peuvent plus oui quand
dans une entreprise on veut un renouveau
si on réunit pas des vins des fonds
d'investissement en disant voilà on a
tous les fonds d'investissement au tour
de table qu'est-ce qu'on fait ensemble
maintenant on a d'abord un projet et à
projets choisis un environ et d'abord un
projet après l'homme incarne et pourquoi
il incarne parce qu'il a les compétences
pour le faire sur est ce qu'on est sûr
que les gens qui ont aujourd'hui dont on
entend parler tous les jours dans
l'actualité ont les compétences qui
l'ont prouvé dans les années qui
viennent d'eux et roulez vous posez là
le problème de la vie politique
française qui est de sa capacité à se
renouveler en effet alors on va quitter
le tumulte de la vie politique
jean-christophe prenantes halles de
dijon da pour dire un mot de l'actualité
internationale avec l'intervention
française qui a donc commencé en
centrafrique la france opère en soutien
de la force africaine
déjà présente sur place mission de
rétablissement de la sécurité dans ce
pays en guerre civile paris agit donc
dans le cadre de la légalité
internationale sous mandat de l'onu
propose d'écouter le chef de l'état
la france est attendu pour éviter une
catastrophe humanitaire
elle sera là j'ai plein de confiance en
nos soldats pour mener cette opération
je sais leur sens du devoir
leurs grandes qualités professionnelles
cette intervention sera rapide elle n'a
pas vocation à durer et je suis sûr de
son succès jean rendrait compte
régulièrement aux français alors cette
intervention fait l'unanimité tout le
monde s'est rangé derrière le président
de la république vous aussi messieurs la
france s'honore à être dans une approche
aussi humaine humanitaires et dans des
pays en grande difficulté
donc je pense que sur cette action tout
le monde doit être solidaire et derrière
nos forces armées aux alors le reprend
son costume de chef de guerre non je ne
crois pas là là c'est assez différent de
l'intervention aux malices d'abord cela
zone d'influencé française il ya une
nécessité à de faire une urgence
humanitaire
néanmoins ça soulève
mais il me semble ça devrait être
l'europe qui intervient dans sa salle et
on se rend compte une fois de plus que
l'europe n'existe pas sur ce terrain là
et que la france retrouve tout seul est
ce que vous réclamez un débat un vrai
débat à l'assemblée nationale sur la
france et l'afrique
je pense que l'afrique nous interpelle
et nous interpellent pour des raisons
humanitaires et nous interpellent pour
des raisons économiques c'est un
milliard un des pays les plus jeunes du
monde une dynamique démographique
incroyable une dynamique économique
probablement incroyable dans les années
à venir
articulée au niveau européen et au
niveau français mais peut-être d'abord
au niveau européen une politique
africaine cohérente constructive
pertinente me semble un élément
fondamental mais quand on voit combien
effectivement l'europe gagnerait à a
démarré par des interventions comme
celle qu'on vient de rappeler ce n'est
pas très encourageant pour la capitale
de l'europe à s'auto saisir d'une
doctrine africaine vous les avez raison
de dire ça parce que qu'est ce qu'on
constate regarder la côte d'ivoire où on
est intervenue pour soutenir permettre
monsieur ouattara d'arriver au pouvoir
ou en tout cas conforté son pouvoir
eh bien on compte on constate que les
investissements français qui
représentait 36 % des investissements
côte d'ivoire il ya quelques années
aujourd'hui c'est plus que 13% alors je
reste vraiment on ne pouvait pas
terminer cette semaine évidemment sans
parler d'un décès il à votre très
important celui de nelson mandela
disparu à l'âge de 95 ans hommage
planétaire la france à la mi ses
drapeaux en berne aujourd'hui si vous
deviez retenir à l'adjectif concernant
nelson mandela si gvt amos et c'est un
symbole et le monde a besoin est là je
rejoins denis jeambar le monde a besoin
de symboles le monde se nourrit aussi de
ses symboles de quoi pour vous symbole
de liberté avec elle quelques l acte de
liberté que d'avoir accepté ces années
reclus isolé emprisonné pour avoir cette
liberté de servir une cause oui moi je
crois que
le symbole de liberté qui a incarné le
visage et le sourire et le sourire de
mandela jamais de haine noyer bouddha
sourire une travail de paix
extraordinaire c'est un très beau
symbole qui s'éteint aujourd'hui mais
qui va s'amplifier probablement dans les
ornières l'avis négatif depuis qu'on a
appris le décès de nelson mandela
tout le monde l'a connu tout le monde a
été le rencontrer et c'est quoi c'est
l'icône des politiques aujourd'hui c'est
devenu un personnage légendaire tout ce
que vous venez de dire est juste il
incarne une sorte d'idéal de la famille
humaine rassemblée et de la démocratie
néanmoins ce qu'il faut voir c'est bien
écouté la france va en rca et tout ce
qu'il apportait malheureusement eh bien
ça ne va pas au delà de son personnage y
compris dans son propre pays où la
violence reste très grande où le taux de
chômage est de 38% et donc où sont les
héritiers de mandela merci beaucoup
merci d'être resté avec nous pour cette
petite page international et tout de
suite le plus de l'hebdo on se projette
en 2025
rendez vous dans un peu plus de dix ans
paris rêve d'accueillir une nouvelle
exposition universelle en 2025
vous êtes l'une des têtes de pont de ce
projet jean christophe fromantin on va
en parler mais d'abord un petit avant
goût de ce projet géant avec simon
barbarie des trottoirs roulants une
première ligne de métro
un petit et un grand palais 50 millions
de visiteurs
nous sommes en 1900 et la france
accueille pour la dernière fois
l'exposition universelle de véritables
olympiades du progrès mais aussi un
formidable levier pour l'économie
alors pourquoi la france ne serait elle
pas à nouveau l'hôte de cet événement en
2025 une candidature portée notamment
par le sénateur-maire socialiste
d'alfortville luc carvounas là où
quelques-uns qui nous écouterait se dire
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette lubie
de finalement deux élus locaux lé maire
de neuilly et d'alfortville qui auraient
envie d'initier ce projet ce qu'il n'y a
pas mieux à faire au moment où on parle
de crise de compétitivité de chômage est
bien au contraire
ce projet ne peut être que fédérateur un
fédérateur économique un booster
d'aménagement du territoire
le projet de la candidature française
s'approprier de façon éphémère les
infrastructures du grand paris et les
monuments existants des grandes villes
françaises
la tour eiffel relooké par les chinois
versa et réinventée par le brésil
chaque exposant se verrait attribuer un
lieu pour une performance qui devra
faire appel aux nouvelles technologies
l'association expo france 2025 créé pour
soutenir le projet a déjà attiré le
soutien de grands acteurs économiques
politiques universitaires ou encore
sportif et je crois qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'audace et d'ambition
projet fort pour un avenir même lointain
première étape être prêt pour le dépôt
des candidatures en 2016 là aussi on
peut comprendre ce vaste projet ce n'est
pas une lubie de deux élus locaux comme
le disais à l'instant
votre collègue sénateur pour vous c'est
un vrai projet fédérateur vous pensez
vraiment que ce type de projet intéresse
encore fait encore révélé les citoyens
ses citoyens et n'a troublé a besoin
d'une sortie de tunnel louis heckel
qu'est ce qu'un tunnel où il ya que du
noir que du noir que du noir c'est
désespérant une porte de sortie c'est ça
qui donne envie d'avancer
quand je regarde la caisse que ce que
les expos universelles ont amené à la
france notamment au 19ème un moment où
pareille on se préoccuper de la
mondialisation elle avait un autre nom
elle avait d'autres caractéristiques
mais la france douter de son avenir de
son modèle de son développement et
aujourd'hui elle doute à nouveau de son
avenir de son modèle iphone d'être
déclassée dans la satire du déclassement
vous le vous l'avez cité tout à l'heure
dans des chiffres et donc je crois qu'au
contraire et les pays émergents nous le
10/10 de la france est un des pays qu'on
admire le plus qu'on reconnaît le plus
qui a le plus à nous apporter
donc c'est à nous et c'est nous qui
devons retrouver cette ce sentiment
d'appartenance et de fierté et cette
audace pour notre pays et on a moins
d'ambitions pour notre la france que
finalement souvent des pays extérieurs
des pays long pour nous en disant mais
vous avez une chance inouïe vous avez
des atouts considérables
donc ce projet ça catalyseur d'espérance
un catalyseur d'énergie c'est redonner
une grande ambition ensemble pour la
france des territoires au coeur du
projet c'est la force du projet oui
parce que notre force notre nos
avantages comparatifs ce sont nos
territoires c'est tout ce qu'on a dans
le tréfonds de nos régions de nos
départements de nos provinces tout ce
qu'on a que les autres n'ont pas est ce
que la fraise que le monde nous
reconnaît elle est facile le monde est
fasciné par nos paysages nos cultures
nos traditions nos savoirs ne permet pas
que marie diouf dia la france en est
d'ailleurs aux france 2000 25e journée
tirées coup c'est la france alors le
grand paris est un territoire de projets
enfin naturellement mais c'est un projet
français après c'est un projet très
ambitieux vous avez tous les
financements pour mener à terme ce grand
pour ce grand projet le bon indicateur
aujourd'hui dans une période de
c'est pas notre capacité à aller
chercher de l'argent public c'est au
contraire notre capacité à faire avec de
l'argent privé et quand il ya toutes ces
grandes entreprises françaises qui
viennent nous aider à financer a préparé
ce projet c'est la preuve qu'elle y voit
aussi un intérêt économique
si avec nono nos réseaux et nos
relations luc carvounas moi et
quelques-uns on avait voté des budgets
publics ont le projet n'aurait aucun
sens
quelqu'un vous ou quelques mots sur la
jada les résultats c'est pour quand le
dépôt du dossier c'est pour 2016 ensuite
il ya un tour du monde à faire pour
vendre notre candidature est un choix en
2018 est ce que vous êtes suivi par le
gouvernement par françois hollande est
ce qu'il vous pousse on démarre par une
mission parlementaire et je crois que
c'est faux fabriquer du consensus sur un
projet comme ça on a fait du consensus
économique maintenant faut qu'on fasse
du consensus politique et une fois qu'on
aura tous et consensus on ira
officiellement saisir le gouverneur
avant de finir cette émission va
reparler de votre actualité présente les
municipales notamment neuilly sur seine
où il ya beaucoup de candidats qui
risquent de se présenter face à vous on
en parlait tout à l'heure notamment le
nom de michèle alliot marie qui est
évoqué
vous le redoutez vous redoutez non je
faisais mon câble j'ai mon bilan j'ai
une confiance extraordinaire et une
relation de confiance avec la population
de la ville qui m'a fait dire que la
différence d'un de quelqu'un qui a une
étiquette politique ou c'est que moi je
suis là je suis devant vous je suis
parlementaire grâce non pas aux
étiquettes qu'on m'a collé mais grâce à
la confiance de la population de l'ue
vis-à-vis de mon projet donc quand vous
êtes porté oui soutenu et j'ai et j'ai
fait dans les dernières aux élections
plus de 70% envoyé par une population
indépendamment de toute étiquette etc
je crois que celui qui a le plus à
craindre c'est lui qui se fait
parachuter martin on avait fait
l'expérience
j'ai vu qu'alliot-marie était derrière
adjoint de saint jean de luz et une
première ajointe à saint-jean-de-luz
aujourd'hui donc voilà je pourrais
expliquer aux gens de saint-jean-de-luz
que dire au revoir maintenant c'est fini
je me rapproche de paris et aux gens de
ic j'arrive
moi je n'ai jamais vu jamais croisé sur
un marché une rude nuit
voyez j'arrive et puis voilà faut voter
pour moi dans le moyeu personnes non
mais cela n'a plus de sens oui ça n'a
pas de sens c'est 75% de défiance qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure c'est qu'on
instrumentalise une population corps
nasstrom andely samantha quand
instrumentalise une ville et là on
instrumentalise martinon a tenté la même
pas été au bout de deux élections
puisqu'il a abandonné 2 mois avant la
fin voilà là on est à trois mois des
élections
on suivra ça sur les chaînes
parlementaires dans trois mois on se
retrouve nous la semaine prochaine katia
bonne semaine à tous et merci de votre
fidélité